the guys who draw what they do is I kind
of give an inspiration and then they go
with it there's stuff in the cartoon
where they they just play with images
and they go as fast as I do personal
foul
the toughest part about making 1992's
Aladdin probably cutting down all of
Robin Williams ad-libs sometimes I crack
myself up the comedian improvised so
much animators had almost 16 hours of
material to work with they take it the
next level and they're the ones who do
this you know the six months of you know
the tedious tedious work but the great
thing is it's all hands on the animated
film made more than a half billion
dollars at the box office worldwide one
major factor
Aladdin's theme song the Oscar winning A
Whole New World Lea Salonga who voiced
the singing role of Jasmine told us she
knew the ballad would be a hit when she
heard the demo it's not just an ordinary
zombie love song makes you just go gooey
inside but it makes you it makes you
feel as if you were on the carpet along
with Aladdin and Jasmine Aladdin was
voiced by actor Scott weinger he told
E.T he threw himself into the role I
really got into it when I was recording
you know I would I'd have to take off my
watch and my shirt because I'd be going
Genie you know what this and that and I
get really wild Aladdin's Adventures
didn't end there 2019's live-action
version grossed more than a billion
globally Aladdin 2 is in the works with
Guy Ritchie back in the director's chair
there's no start date and no word on if
Will Smith will step back into the genie
slippers you know Robin Williams didn't
leave a whole lot of room for
improvement
[Music]
foreign